welcome to Stratus own the only way to
start their migration journey my name is
tad 9 Stein and I'm a senior program
manager in the Google cloud we also have
Carl Co she's CEO of Stratus own here
today to talk about the benefits of
strata zone and how it will help you
accelerate your cloud journey one of the
first pieces that you want to focus on
when looking to migrate to the cloud is
the assessment and discovery phase doing
things proper early on will yield
amazing results in the end so one of the
first pieces is to make sure that your
team is properly educated on the cloud
and that your engineers are ready to
actually move to the cloud once you
start the process so things like
training are critical in this phase also
you'll want to focus on the
experimentation it's very important that
they get to break things in order to
understand how to get through some very
interesting cloud paradigms during your
migration and also during the assessment
phase you need to catalog all of your
applications so we typically create
three buckets those which are easy hard
and can't move but when doing this how
do you go about sorting your
applications and also how do you go
about taking a first mover in a typical
enterprise there are many applications
which are interwoven so doing this step
properly is paramount to a successful
migration so as we discuss examples of
application sorting you can see that we
have those systems which might be
disconnected and non-critical this might
be something like a marketing website
backup an archive or a dev test
environment where you're literally able
to take them from their current
environment whether on-premise or
another cloud and lift and shift them
into Google cloud very easily
you'll also then have your set of
applications that fall under what we
call hard those are things like back
office applications data analytics
they're usually non critical but they're
very interconnected
so those might not be the best first
mover but they're perfect for the cloud
and you might want to do those in a
second or third wave then we also have
those that just cannot move to the cloud
that maybe you're running on legacy
hardware which just doesn't fit in a
cloud paradigm so what are the business
characteristics of a good first mover
well when you
think about it we want those
applications which are not business
critical and also which are not edge
cases you want to find applications that
are stateless that as we've said
previously can literally be lifted and
shifted and that makes a great first
mover because it allows you to learn the
interworkings not only the cloud but of
the migration process you also focus on
apps that do not require much
refactoring for your first mover's it
makes no sense spending a ton of time
having your developers repoed an app
when there are other applications in
your environment that can quickly be
brought into the cloud as you're working
through things like compliance also be
aware of those applications which do
have compliance challenges or
third-party proprietary licenses when
moving to the cloud or any sort of
migration you have to think about
cutover windows so when choosing that
first louver make sure it's an
application where you can accept that
downtime to your business so that when
you lift and shift it's not a
significant impact to the business and
then most importantly throughout all of
these iterations you're gonna build a
knowledge base for your engineers and
for your team and for your business as a
whole as it relates to crown with cloud
migration this is why it's critical to
find those right first movers so that
you can build a knowledge base which you
then will build off of even further so
Google's created a cloud migration
methodology and it consists of four
stages the first which we just refer to
as the assessment phase which is where
you understand what's currently in your
environment how it connects and what
would be needed when you start looking
to move to the cloud next you have the
Foundation's phase and this is where you
actually set up the cloud for the first
time so what you do is you create a
landing zone you set up networking
identity and access management security
rules that are in compliance with what
your company desires once the foundation
is properly set up you can then go
through the migration phase which
ensures that what you're migrating goes
into an environment that is properly
sound based on your company's objectives
and security model finally the last
phase is optimizing once you've lifted
and shifted your applications to the
cloud now you can start optimizing and
leverage cloud native technologies to
really benefit from what the cloud
brings now I want to quickly touch on
the assessment
face because this is often the one where
people get stuck and the reason why is
actually understanding what's in your
environment can be very difficult often
editor process of applications that have
spanned upwards of 20 years and often
the information is not readily available
by leveraging a tool like Stratus own
you're able to easily deploy their data
collection utilities within your
environment collect the data of how your
applications interact review the
analytics and also optimize cloud
strategy of what those applications will
look like during the migration and also
create a business case and roadmap which
you can present to your IT leadership
and corporate executives now the five
needs to create a cloud strategy are to
have a scalable and non intrusive
discovery process or assessment phase
which is what stratasim brings to bear
as well as the ability to define cloud
fit and suitability we discussed how not
every application is a good fit for the
cloud and by laboratory strata zone
you're able to quickly understand which
one of those applications might need to
be retooled or might not be a fit also
defining the shared consumption plan so
delivering the highest savings a return
on investment within Google Cloud maybe
understanding that certain things that
ran in your on-premise environment you
can adjust the metrics of RAM CPU to
something a little less and get
significant savings without a
performance it also defensible and
competitive financials so getting the
information that you're then going to
give to your CFO your CEO that clearly
defines what your cloud strategy is from
a financial aspect and what it looks
like over time and then also a
consumable roadmap now that you
understand the financials now that you
understand have what's going to move
what does that look like over time and
how are we going to get our entire
organization into the cloud so with that
being said I'd like to introduce Karl
Koshi CEO of Stratus own to talk more
about Stratus own and how you can
leverage it today
thanks dad so we're gonna spend a minute
talking about what strategies on
delivers to the customer there are two
levels of deliverables first we're
talking about the basics the first set
of deliverables is around financials
business case and roadmap so let's go
through some of those number one
strategy one helps you to very
efficiently discover your environment
this is an agentless data collection
process that's very quick after this is
done stratas own will then capture the
customer requirements which it overlays
on the underlying data thereby helping
to fit pick the best fit products and
ultimately arrive at the what goes where
in win this is the crux of what Stratus
on delivers that includes a delivery
model which could determine how you
consume cloud is this infrastructure as
a service platform as a service and so
on or is something not meant to build a
cloud in your implementation model so
you decide on your in your cloud model
such as your hybrid model a private
public or otherwise blended model that
you may want to use after this the
platform helps you develop your business
case creates your adoption roadmap and
then also create a migration plan some
of the advanced deliverables include
machine shaping optimization roadmap
modeling
pads analysis which is platform
as-a-service analysis and then most
importantly dependency mapping this is
an important component of what customers
look for in their environment to see
what talks to what and how all of your
applications are related this is a very
critical component needed when you
decide this what of your environment is
going to move first second last and and
also decide on the timing for those with
this we'll go now into how you can use
stratas own and how you can how you what
the process looks like to to implement
strategy so the first step in the
process is to register either as a
customer or a partner can register their
customer at go GCPs strata zone calm
once again that's go GCP that's strata
zone calm the customer then receives one
or more data collectors which are simple
install shield applications that they
will use to install the application
their environments it could be one if
the collector per environment or one
collector across multiple environments
this is the customer's choice the second
step in the process is where the
customers technical administrators
deploy the data collectors after
customizing it to their needs
this could including deciding what IP
ranges they want to collect upon or what
environments they want to collect upon
once that collector is deployed within
24 hours customers partners as well as
your cloud provider can come up there
and take a look and see what those
results look like this includes the
analysis of the environment optimization
of assets optimization of you of your
machine shapes and and how you would
consume cloud as well as developing a
roadmap and moving on to the next steps
in your planning now these strata zone
data collector is agentless it is all
encrypted it's lightweight and most
importantly customers can decide what
data feels they want to anonymize from
within their firewall that reaches the
strata so mortal so this is a custom
anonymization ability given to customers
we would take let's take a second and
talk about data security in and the data
that's collected the data that's
collected primarily focuses on machine
data things like performance installed
application names network traffic
processes and services that are running
in the utilization of all of these
components what we do not collect is
user information or profiles
any data that's underlying the
applications anything in your database
or file storage application
configuration files for example or
typically any data that is subject to
any regulatory compliances all the data
is encrypted in transit and at rest and
customers can anonymize any data they
see fit from leaving their firewall and
going to the shredders own portal Thank
You coral so as one of the next steps
for you you can actually start your
learning journey with Google Cloud today
and most importantly actually get
hands-on with strata zone to run through
your own assessment within a fully
functional Google cloud environment to
do so and take the introduction to
Stratus own assessment hands-on lab you
can register for access
to Google cloud learnings learning tools
one of those being our hands-on labs
platform quick labs where you can
actually start the exact lab for strata
zone and leverage the functionality that
Karl spoke about today prior to that
Karl will go through a demo which will
show how the product is leveraged and
how you can benefit from it for your
cloud migration hello everyone and
welcome to a demo of the Stratus own
platform this demo will be focused on
the basic assessment we will first walk
you through the process of starting an
assessment reviewing your assessment
data and finally generating a report
showing your cloud fit and business case
to get started you will first need to
register your customer at go gcpd razón
comm when you do so you will also
receive a separate registration link via
email once you create your username and
password you'll be able to log in at
portal dot resume comm and get to this
dashboard that I'm looking at now so
once you're here how does Straz own help
you and your customer on the cloud
migration journey well we have two
different modules associated with the
assessment first is the analyze module
and this is where all of the raw data
from the environment is collected it's
also where we review that data and
validate that it's the complete set of
migration candidates the analyze module
will also allow you to create an initial
business case the plan module is here
for more advanced price modeling as this
allows you to do custom groupings custom
right sizing and also select particular
VM instances per server so let's start
with the analyze module let's start with
the analyze module when you first click
on the analyze module you'll be
presented with the analyze dashboard in
this dashboard you can view the total
number of servers collected into
inventory you can view the number of
those servers that are Windows and Linux
and which ones are marked out of scope
you can also view the total virtual core
count the vram and the allocated storage
in the bottom right here you can view
the server age distribution and in the
top right you can view our strata
fitzcore which is a measure of
infrastructure cloud readiness next
let's view the summary tab the summary
tab is still taken in aggregate of all
customer servers however it does allow
you to view some metrics that are not
available in the dashboard tab for
instance you can view the exact
operating system distribution of the
customer environment as well as that
environments memory distribution in the
bottom left you can view some basic
asset statistics about the environment
and in the bottom right you can view the
asset utilization as a percentage of the
total allocated capacity on the left
side toolbar you can view additional
details about the operating systems
storage memory server age and the
installed software within the
environment of course you won't be able
to view this information until the scan
is actually running to view the progress
of the scan access the assessments tab
at the top after you click on
assessments you'll be presented with
your different assessment groups in this
example we have a group for East Coast
West Coast primary data center and
anything that's not Windows or Linux
which must be a manual asset entry as
you can see we have one collector for
each data center location the general
recommendation is to have one per
location but keep in mind that the
customer can install more than one per
location if desired and any duplicate
assets that are scanned by both
collectors will be automatically removed
by the system note that for each
collector you can check the status of
the scan as well as the server count of
the expected values for the status it
will either say complete or installed if
it's been started or it will say not
started if it has not been installed and
connected to the web service
after the collectors are installed and
configured you'll be able to view the
inventory as it comes in to do so
access the inventory tab at the top now
that we have accessed this specific
server at the top you can see all of the
basic configuration info this will tell
you not only what is the server name and
IP but also whether it's a virtual
machine or bare metal
how many CPU cores are allocated how
much RAM is allocated what operating
system it's running on as well as the
processor of the host machine if you
scroll down you can also view graphs
that outline the performance data or the
utilization of each of those components
over time similar to the summary tab
more information can be accessed on the
left-hand toolbar for instance clicking
on the storage tab will allow you to
view details about the exact storage
partitions what's free what's not if you
click on network you can view the exact
network configuration as well as what
subnet that server is located in you can
also view running services on that
server
running processes installed software if
there are any as well as memory
utilization metrics and CPU utilization
metrics by process what I have just
shown you from the inventory tab
represents all of the configuration and
performance data that we have collected
from each server the last piece of
information that we have are the network
dependencies to view the network
dependencies click on the dependency tab
at the top the analyze dependency tab
allows you to view server to server
network dependencies by selecting an
individual server to select that server
you can do so by accessing your
collector groups and a specific
collector or you can just click on
details on the left-hand toolbar to view
all available servers once you've
selected the server that you want click
on the eyeglasses symbol to view it this
will now provide you with a graphical
view
of the network dependencies as well as a
more specific view in a table format
below as you can see we're collecting
the protocol source and target IP source
and target port as well as the installed
app on the source machine all of this
information comes from in that stack
command and is included as part of the
agentless scan via strata probe one
critical feature of this tab is its
ability to detect unscanned devices you
can see an example of this down here
where it says on scan device if I expand
that you can see the same net stat
details about that one scan device you
can also view that device in a graphical
format up here there is a nun scan
device button that will bundle any
unscanned devices if you double click
that and click this in the top right to
need in the view you can see that there
are actually two distinct IP addresses
now we have not scanned these devices
and so the only thing that we know about
them are their IPs but this is still
nonetheless useful for a scoping
exercise to ensure that all target
servers are being included in the
analysis the next tab we will look at is
the strata fit table the strata fit tab
is a machine level indicator of cloud
readiness it does not take into account
broader server-side application
structure however it does look at each
individual server and determine based on
that servers capacity and operating
system whether it is ready for a lift
and shift to the cloud as you can see
the strata fit is represented by three
different scores low medium and high
high are the easy movers these are the
servers that are already modernized and
ready for lift and shift lows are
anything that is incompatible for the
cloud entirely usually this is due to an
older operating system say an old CentOS
version like CentOS 4 or 5 or Windows
2000 / 2003 that are deemed incompatible
for the cloud the servers that are
flagged medium are somewhere in between
where they are technically
enough for the cloud however they tend
to have a higher number of network
dependencies with other servers this
means that they are most likely involved
in some type of broader more complicated
app structure that may make it more
difficult to move if you would like to
investigate why particular server
received the score that it did you can
do so on the left-hand toolbar under
details if you click on details it will
list out all of the scored servers from
low to medium to high if you want to
know why a server received a score other
than high simply click on the drop down
for that server and view those reasons
in sentence format note that the strata
fit score has 6 different parameters you
can customize how sensitive each of
these parameters are on the left hand
toolbar under actions customize
parameters if you click on customize
parameters you will see all 6 of them
listed out and you can adjust this
slider bar to change the sensitivity of
each to finish up the analyze module
let's take a look at the reports tab
within the reports tab it's important to
note that any of the information
contained in the analyze module can be
exported as a report at the top our
summary reports which tend to be either
slideshows or PDFs at the bottom are
detailed reports which are essentially
CSV dumps of the raw information to
generate an executive summary report
slideshow create a summary report first
click on the button for that then select
the groups whether collectors or bill
groups that you would like to include in
the slideshow
you can then select your baseline vendor
catalog which we will usually use the
private data center compare that to the
various Google catalogs name it and
click create report after your report is
finished building you can download it by
clicking this icon note that you can
download it as a Google slides as well
if you prefer now let's open this up so
we can take a look at what is produced
so for starters it will produce some
introductory slides like a table of
contents as well as a background on the
overall assessment process it will also
produce a slide outlining the different
collectors that were set up
then it's going to jump right into the
high-level findings so this is the
high-level configuration here followed
by some more advanced metrics like the
utilisation percentage in the bottom
right and then jumping into the cloud
readiness so this is the strata fit
score which is an infrastructure cloud
readiness score and we also have a pads
fit score so this is going to identify
any potential pass candidates after
those high-level findings will show that
financial comparison and this is what
that's going to look like after covering
the financial comparison there will be a
couple of slides talking about the high
level next steps and this is intended to
lead into the next conversation for an
advanced service thanks so much for that
demo Carl really impressive and with
that being said I just wanted to recall
for everyone who's watching that you can
also do exactly what Carl just did in a
full hands-on lab environment prior to
deploying strata zone within your
environment to do so and take the
introduction to Stratus own assessments
hands-on lab follow the first link to
register her access to Google Cloud
learnings platforms and then click on
the following link so that you can start
the lab
actually leverage strata zone within a
real-world hands-on environment prior to
actually deploying it in your enterprise
environment with that being said Carl
and I would both like to thank you for
your time we look forward to seeing you
on Google Cloud and we hope you really
enjoy the benefits that Stratus own will
bring to your business thank you thank
you